- All right.
We've been all music all hour,
and we've got one more musical
story to finish things up.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and applauding)
A little over a year ago
a group of guys in Sweden
were hanging out at a bachelor party
when they decided to start singing.
Unbeknownst to the group,
one of the men recorded the whole scene,
and put it up on Tik Tok
just to show a friend.
But more than one friend saw the video.
In a few hours, tens of
thousands had watched.
To date 22 million have.
Since then they've
become an official group
called Dad Harmony.
They perform on radio shows and tour,
and they still post videos
like this amazing NSYNC cover.
♪ No man, no cry ♪
♪ Maybe that's why ♪
♪ Every little thing I do ♪
♪ Never seemed enough for you ♪
♪ You don't wanna lose it again ♪
♪ But I'm not like them ♪
♪ Baby when you finally ♪
♪ Get to love somebody ♪
♪ Guess what ♪
♪ It's gonna be me ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Just hanging out with
little Spiderman on his lap.
We have this amazing harmonizing dads
on the line right now.
Everybody say hello to
Sebastian, Peter, Adam,
Thomas and Michael.
(audience cheering and applauding)
What's up, y'all?
I'm gonna start with, look,
I wanna know who's singing that bass?
Who's holding that down?
Which one of you has got that voice?
Come on, now.
- It's me.
♪ Hey ♪
- That's a sexy voice man.
Sexy bass.
Well Peter, I'm gonna start with you.
First, how did this video happen?
Who posted it?
- Yeah, it started at my bachelor party.
We were in a hot tub,
and we sang the song "The Weatherman"
as we usually do when
we are with each other.
And my brother Thomas was posting this
on Tik Tok with his, I think,
seven followers at that time.
And it all exploded,
and now we have 22 million.
- I love that you dudes were just
hanging out in the hot tub,
and you were like "We
should probably sing."
I love it.
So, Sebastian, Adam, now you're performing
and you're touring, right?
- Yeah.
I mean after it went viral
we got invited to various morning shows
on television and radio around the world.
And from then on it just kept going,
and now we're also doing live shows.
- Unfortunately we do not bring
the kids with us on stage,
but they love to join
us when we sing at home.
- I know, I love Spiderman
just lying on the lap in the video.
It's just a good...
Firetrucks, there's everything.
It's just amazing.
Well you sound beautiful.
Your harmonies are incredible.
Thank you so much for posting,
and inspiring all of us.
And keep singing.
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell dings)
And that's not all.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Our season one partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Precise, the go to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable dads
just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000 which I think is about
10,5000 Swedish Kroner.
So split that up how you will.
Thank you guys so much for joining us.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Justin Timberlake, Troy,
Cassana, (indistinct).
Have a great day,
and if it's not change it.
(audience cheering and applauding)